happy new year 2016 to all of my YouTube
subscribers and viewers we've got a lot
of really great stuff coming up this
this year and as usual with these update
videos I'm going to talk about what
happened to the month before that is
December 2015 and what we've got coming
up in the month ahead january two
thousand sixteen or the month we're in
and since it's the end of the year or at
the beginning of a new year i think i
might do a little bit more retrospective
about 2015 and a little bit more about
2016 before that i always like to do a
little preview of three big things that
are coming up in this month so this
month what we've got are some really
exciting talks the first of them is a
workshop that i'll be giving at the
hudson business lounge in downtown
Milwaukee the place where I do some of
my work and it's part of our ideas in
action series so I'll tell you a little
bit more about that when we get to the
January portion I will just say this if
he has to do with new year's resolutions
and stoicism the second big thing that
we've got is our first library to lack
here in our new place in Wisconsin we've
partnered with a number of different
area libraries will talk more about that
in a moment but specifically with the
Brookfield public library I'm going to
be doing a year-long series like the
ones i did in kingston and this time
it's going to be about worlds of science
fiction and fantasy and the
philosophical themes that can be found
in them so that's that cloth the first
talk in that series is coming up this
month and then the last thing I wanted
to talk about was actually a development
having to do it the half-hour Hagel
series so we are going to hit an
important milestone during the month of
January towards the end of the one and
that is we are going to be finished
with the second main section
self-consciousness all the videos for
that will be done by the end of the
month if I remain on schedule and will
be going into the next big section which
is reason which is pretty sizable
portion of the book you can see you down
here's here's that section itself reason
comes before the next section spirit
which comes before religion which comes
before absolute knowing and at that time
we're at the end of the work so we're
actually making some really great
progress through the work and I'm really
excited to be going into a whole new
dialectic with that so let's talk now
about the month of December and a little
bit about the Year 2015 itself December
we didn't do a lot of events everything
we did was online i did a hangout with
Tom Richie somebody who I like to
partner with who does AP History prep
really interesting guy from the
Carolinas and we talked a bit about
enlightenment and modern philosophy and
technology and all that sort of stuff
you can see that on his site because it
was a hangout on air I also did another
one of my monthly public half-hour Hagel
Q&A a hangouts and get some good talks
about that I actually had some
interesting ideas that will show up in
the half hour Hagel blog hopefully later
this month from that the main thing that
I did during the month of December took
a lot of my time was finished up with
the Epictetus discourses class that I
was teaching for the global Center for
Advanced Studies was a four-week online
class we had about a hundred people may
be a little bit more than that sign up
about a good 20 people coming to the
weekly video conferences asking some
great questions some interesting student
work has come out of it including a blog
that got started by one
my students i'll put a link to that
really interesting stuff about applying
stoicism to the service industry i
really enjoyed the class a lot i didn't
get to as much of the material
generation as i would have liked but i
did manage to shoot about close to 50
videos for the class so that's that's a
lot and i created a number of handouts
and a number of lesson pages conducted
forums and all that so that was that was
a big event and video work i already
mentioned that that we have the you know
epictetus core concept videos you
probably saw quite a few of those in the
month i only shot for a half hour hagel
videos in part because once i got
towards the holiday part of the month i
started to think well I should probably
take some sort of break and I did more
than I had in other years and I have
that one unboxing video that people seem
to like as well with the Billy bookshops
so that was the video work that I did it
did a bit of blogging not as much as I'd
intended or hope to do but you know some
some writing I did a bit of academic
writing as well some of them was going
back and looking at older stuff that had
written and you know fixing it up a bit
mostly having to do with coding going
from old programs like word perfect to
you know the modern versions of word
where you know the codes are all
different and we did a lot of
reorganization and rethinking things you
know for example I cleaned up my desktop
on my my laptop which took a
surprisingly long time because there's
so many files that needed to go places
you notice things along those lines
unpacking books putting things in their
proper places getting things onto the
hard drive where they belong backing up
files all that sort of end of your stuff
in to bring it to a close about that
2015 was a pretty good year overall made
a lot of growth in the YouTube channels
did quite a few
interesting talks I actually tallied up
the number of public appearances that I
put in it was something like you know
who's in the 20s so a lot of a lot of
great discussions coming out of that I
generated a ton of content that I'm
eventually going to be repurposing and
we we made some really important
connections let's talk now about what
we've got coming up in this year 2016
it's a lot of stuff so I'm not going to
try and pack it all into this video but
I will tell you about what we've got
happening in January and then I'll give
you a few hints about what's on the
horizon this is going to be a pretty
important year for us at reason I oh so
like I said I've got several events
coming up that I mentioned in the big
three things January thirteenth we have
the first of the ideas in action
workshops this is something a little bit
different that I've done in the past at
previous lectures or discussions or
workshops I made it just you know open
whoever wants to come can just show up
with this you actually need to take it
in part because we're confining it to 12
participants we already have two of the
tickets spoken for because people
already signed up for them the day that
I posted it you'll see the link down
below in the description if you're in
the Milwaukee area and you want to come
to this this workshop you need to get
yourself a ticket so that we know that
we're saving a space free this one is
using stoic philosophy to keep new
year's resolutions so each month I'm
going to be doing one of these workshops
very hands-on fairly intensive workshop
where I'm going to be doing a bit of
teaching about key ideas in stoic
practical philosophy or Aristotelian
practical philosophy and then we're
going to be doing application people are
beginning you know work worksheets that
they're going to fill out we're going to
actually workshop them which means
having discussion you know what's your
resolution is a reasonable one do you
think you need to revise it you know how
would I Stewart look at it that's the
sort of thing that we're going
doing next month by the way for for you
know the theme of Valentine's Day we're
going to turn the Aristotle and talk
about Aristotle's famous distinction
between three different kinds of
friendship and how that might play into
romantic relationships or other
relationships so a lot of those coming
up this one is January thirteenth at the
Hudson business lounge the second event
that we've got coming up is the next day
january fourteenth and it is at the
brookfield public library like it said
before it's the first of a 12 lecture
series that i'll be doing on worlds of
fantasy and science fiction and on the
philosophical themes in them so you know
who can you expect to see coming up well
you don't think about Isaac Asimov's
foundation series and the world that he
creates and what's going on
philosophically then it really
represents an Enlightenment kind of
attitude towards things or CS Lewis's
space trilogy you know we're not going
to Narnia but we will do these very very
interesting works Tolkien will talk
about we're going to talk about Frank
Herbert's dune we're going to talk about
bourbon peaks gorman gasp trilogy we'll
talk about some Ursula Kayla Queen
there's a lot of people who are going to
cover the very first one is a bit more
general because it's going to be an
introduction to this this lengthy series
that I'm doing and I'll be video
recording those so people can you know
if it can't make it to brookfield which
obviously is only the case for you know
a small amount of my viewership they can
they can watch them later comment on
them I made and create a website for
this the other thing that we've got
coming up is on january twentieth and
this is the public he half hour Hagel Q
and a series of one of the things that I
committed to when I began crowd funding
the half-hour Hagel project on Patrian
was that after i reached a certain level
of support from my patrons i would offer
something to the general public so what
I what I do is offer the
Google Hangouts if you're interested in
it all you need to do is stay tuned to
my Google+ or Facebook the day of the
Hangout because I will post the link
there then you just jump in and you can
participate any questions that you've
got about Hagel bring it to me and I
will do my best to feel them those are
the events so far scheduled for January
we might have other things coming up
depending on if I get further bookings
video you got a lot of the video stuff
coming up this month half hour Hagel i'm
going to do six videos like it said that
will take us to the end of the section
self-consciousness and into the new
section reason by the way I should
mention if you're interested in becoming
a patron you get perks by doing so
including you know entry to a special
Patriot exclusive Q&A session that I
hold monthly but all sorts of other cool
stuff as well if you're interested in
supporting a great digital project
consider becoming a patron as you know
something to do for the new year I'm
also doing a video about the shooting
process people have been asking you know
what is it like for you to produce these
YouTube videos so the half of our hagel
ones are the ones that require the most
work out of all the videos that I do and
what I've done so far is is shot a bit
of the process that goes into them for
each half hour installment we're talking
about four to five hours worth of actual
work on my part and so you'll see
something about that coming out later
this this month I've got a lot more
Epictetus core concept videos coming out
this month and probably the next month
because I've got so many of them that I
created for the course the events of
course I'm going to try to record if I
have the time and that's a big if this
month I will try to shoot a current
event video or a philosophy self-study
video
or more personal video but I can't
promise anything this month later months
you'll start seeing those videos coming
out what else have we got going on I got
a lot of other kinds of work on the on
the docket for this month so we've
already had some meetings and I've got
more meetings coming up a lot of
conversations some of them with with
local people some of them with other
people and institutions out of the area
I'm developing curriculum for priority
thinking which I've joined as a team
member an organization very proud to be
a part of I'm working also on a webinar
free webinar and a course that I'm going
to bring out not this month but but in
later months but I'm doing a lot of the
backend work for it right now and what
this is about is how to become a
knowledge source on youtube how to
generate a channel that people would
turn to and say oh yeah this is this is
great stuff and so it's designed for you
know people in academia who want to
start incorporating video work into
their portfolio people who want to go
off on their own and take the knowledge
that they have and you know create a
YouTube following people who are
interested in that sort of stuff and
perhaps even a lifelong learners who
exhibited some sort of interest in
creating their own content many of them
really know quite a lot have been
spending a lot of time studying
important classic text so why am i doing
that in part because it's something that
people have been coming to me for the
last year and a half and asking me to
help them out with because I've been
doing you know this old channel is that
so teach what you know this is something
i'm going to start teaching and it's
gonna be the first
a number of different courses and
webinars that we're going to start while
offering through a reason I out for the
webinar where we're going to be
partnering with scholar preneur Scott
ranks somebody who I greatly respect and
who's making some really interesting
inroads as an academic who does his word
in a very public and practical way he
does it with history and also with
teaching academics how to do stuff
outside the Academy I do it with
philosophy but you know we're really
aligned on the same plane when it comes
to you know what's going to happen with
education so that is part of what I'm
going to be spending a lot of time on
later this month I'm also going to be
this this year probably not coming out
this month but I'm going to be starting
to work out I'm going to be doing
podcasts and I'm going to start with
taking the videos that i have and
turning them into podcast people have
been asking me for several years now
could you make these into podcasts
because I listen to these while I'm on
my way to work or doing gardening or you
know doing other things you know so I'm
going to start doing that this is
something new for me I've created a few
podcasts and posted them in archive.org
of talks that that I gave here and there
where I didn't have good at video
footage but to actually go through and
take the movie files and then turn them
into sound files and perhaps even take
out portions where nothing interesting
it's happening or you know fix the sound
somehow that's a bit of a learning curve
for me so that will happen in 2016 I'm
not quite sure exactly when but we're
beginning to work for it here in January
I'm going to be doing more blogging and
so you know you can stay tuned for that
we've got a piece coming out in stoicism
today
game and hopefully I'll do some vlogging
as well for the partially examined life
I've also got my own blogs so you know
it's going to be kind of spread out but
I do want to get more more writing done
I've got some other writing projects
some of them are you know strictly
academic the sort of stuff you've been
hearing me talk about of these these
update videos for years taking
conference papers and turn them into
articles making good on promises I made
to write this or that working at my book
projects and some of them are more
popularly oriented which will probably
culminate in and self-published ebooks
coming out this this year that's
something that I do want to get into I
think there's a great demand for for
very inexpensive ebooks about philosophy
that might actually incorporate some of
the video resources and other things
that I've been creating over the years
so the last thing I'll talk about as far
as 2016 and specifically January goes is
the newsletter I you know started
creating a newsletter for my my local
library you know the people who would
attend the events month after month
after month so I could keep them updated
about what was going on Hudson Valley
and some time since we moved here to
Milwaukee I haven't put out any new news
letters I want to start putting out
newsletters you know either two or three
times a month probably somewhat theme so
maybe some of them will focus more on
what's going on with video projects and
simple focus more on what's going on
with you know local talks and workshops
and some will focus more on other suffer
I haven't quite sorted it out exactly
yet but if you're interested in being on
our mailing list so that you find out
what's going on you know through reason
I oh
which is most of my activities you can
even sign up for it I'm including the
link here and I will you know start
putting those out fairly early this
month because I do want to publicize the
events that we have here in Milwaukee so
if you're interested at all and being on
our mailing list go ahead and join up
and I will keep you updated about
courses and videos and works in
workshops and talks and other
opportunities that we have here so
that's the end of this fairly long
update video I wish you a very
prosperous and happy new year 2016 you
know good time now to start laying all
the groundwork for whatever it is that
you want to do during this coming year
and like i said if you're in the
Milwaukee area come to our events